On Thursday, January 22nd, I'll be hosting a conversation with Nate DeMayo of the Memory Palace at KQED in San Francisco. I could not be more of a fan of Nate in his writing, which is the best in all of podcasting. Please come see us and say hi. Again, that's the Memory Palace live at KQED in San Francisco on Thursday, January 22nd. We'll have a link to tickets in the show notes. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Michael Beirut is one of the best known.
1月22日星期四，我将在旧金山KQED主持一场与《记忆宫殿》（The Memory Palace）播客创作者内特·德马约（Nate DeMayo）的对话。我非常崇拜内特，他的文字是所有播客中最棒的。请一定要来现场和我们打个招呼。再次提醒，那是1月22日星期四在旧金山KQED举办的《记忆宫殿》现场活动。我们会在节目介绍中提供购票链接。这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible），我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。迈克尔·贝鲁特（Michael Beirut）是美国最著名的设计师之一。
designers in America. You probably interact with design from Michael and his team every day, like the Verizon V checkmark, or the logos for Yahoo and Slack, or redesigns for brands like MasterCard, Sacks Fifth Avenue, and the New York Jets. Michael even designed the logo for Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign, that H with the horizontal arrow for the crossbar. But before all that, in 1985, Michael Beirut was 27 years old and early in his career. He was working at the firm founded by legendary designer Massimo Vignali. One day, Michael was handed an assignment that seemed pretty straightforward. The International Design Center of New York had two events coming up, and they wanted
你可能每天都在与迈克尔及其团队设计的作品互动，比如威瑞森（Verizon）的“V”形对勾，雅虎（Yahoo）和Slack的标志，或是万事达卡（MasterCard）、萨克斯第五大道精品百货（Saks Fifth Avenue）和纽约喷气机队（New York Jets）的品牌重塑。迈克尔甚至还设计了希拉里·克林顿（Hillary Clinton）总统竞选活动的标志，那个带有水平箭头作为横杠的“H”。但在这一切之前，1985年，27岁的迈克尔·贝鲁特正处于职业生涯早期。他当时在传奇设计师马西莫·维涅里（Massimo Vignelli）创立的公司工作。一天，迈克尔接到了一项看起来相当简单的任务。纽约国际设计中心（International Design Center of New York）即将举办两场活动，他们希望
Michael to create the invitations. One was going to be an exhibition of what they thought of then say as avant-garde furniture. Dramatic shaped chairs, they could have like slender little feet that would terminate in bright-colored teal balls, you know, if you can picture that. I don't know. Then the other thing was a lecture by some scientists from NASA, from the space program, who were experts on designing interiors and things for people to use in outer space.
迈克尔为这些活动设计邀请函。其中一场是他们当时认为属于前卫家具的展览。造型夸张的椅子，它们可能有纤细的小脚，末端是亮青色的球体，你知道的，如果你能想象出那个画面。我不知道。另一场是来自NASA空间项目的科学家举办的讲座，他们是设计太空用品和室内环境的专家。
Michael started thinking about the two invitations. But then his client made a change that threw Michael for a loop. It turns out the design center didn't have enough money to pay for separate invitations, and so the invitations had to be. combined. Now Michael had to figure out a way to advertise two very different events on the same sheet of paper. This decision did not sit well with a young Michael Beirut. And I remember being like really not just chagrin, but actually kind of angry about this. I thought it was like real rugpole. Each going to be directed to a different audience. They were so different in character
迈克尔开始构思这两份邀请函。但随后客户做出的一个变动让迈克尔陷入了困境。原来设计中心没有足够的预算支付两份单独的邀请函，所以这两份邀请函必须合并。现在，迈克尔必须想办法在同一张纸上宣传两场截然不同的活动。这个决定让年轻的迈克尔·贝鲁特感到很不舒服。“我记得当时不仅是懊恼，甚至还有点生气。我觉得这简直是胡闹。它们本应针对不同的受众。它们的风格差异如此之大，
that any attempt to merge them would basically rob each of them of whatever kind of a attraction they might have for their constituency. I went on in these terms for a while. Michael Beirut had a big challenge on his hands, advertising a furniture show and a lecture about designing for outer space on the same invitation. Ultimately, he came up with an inspired way to solve the problem. He would make the invitation reversible. I just like drew on a piece of paper a little drawing that if you looked at it one way,
以至于任何试图将它们融合在一起的做法，基本上都会剥夺它们各自对目标受众的吸引力。”我当时就是这么想的。迈克尔·贝鲁特面临着巨大的挑战：要在同一张邀请函上宣传家具展和太空设计讲座。最终，他想出了一个巧妙的解决方法。他要把邀请函设计成可翻转的。“我只是在纸上画了一个小草图，如果你从一个方向看，
it looked like a funny little coffee table with those little legs with balls on the end of them, sticking out at an angle at the base. Then at the very top was a vase of flowers with sort of some little flower arrangement bursting out of it. But if you turned it upside down, the legs became antennas, and the vase and flowers became the exhaust and the engine that looked like it was taking off. So it looked like a coffee table with the vase of flowers. If you looked at it one way, you turn it upside down, it looked like a rocket ship taking off the other way.
它看起来像一张有趣的小咖啡桌，有着那些末端带球的小腿，在底部呈一定角度伸出。最上面是一个花瓶，里面有一些小花束喷涌而出。但如果你把它倒过来，腿就变成了天线，花瓶和花朵变成了正在起飞的火箭的尾气和引擎。所以它看起来像一张带花瓶的咖啡桌。如果你从一个方向看是这样，把它倒过来，它看起来就像一艘正在起飞的火箭。”
Michael wrote the event details for the furniture show at one end of the page and the details for the NASA show upside down at the bottom of the page. It was truly an elegant way to solve the problem. Even now, Michael Beirut still loves talking about this invitation because it was a breakthrough for him. It was the beginning of a long line of clever, innovative designs he's created over a four-decade career. In 2025, Michael announced he was stepping
迈克尔在纸的一端写下了家具展的活动详情，在纸的底部倒着写下了NASA活动的详情。这确实是一个解决问题的优雅方案。即使在今天，迈克尔·贝鲁特仍然喜欢谈论这张邀请函，因为它对他来说是一个突破。这是他四十多年职业生涯中一系列巧妙、创新设计作品的开端。2025年，迈克尔宣布他将
away from his role as a partner at the design firm Pentagram. And now he's entering what he calls his semi-retirement. We've had Michael on the show before back in 2017 to discuss logos. And on the occasion of his semi-retirement, we invited him back to talk about his career, his design philosophy, and some of the most interesting trends in graphic design. Here is my talk with my friend, Michael Beirut. You announced earlier this year that you were stepping back from Pentagram. What did that look like for you?
卸任五角设计公司（Pentagram）合伙人的职务。现在他进入了所谓的“半退休”状态。我们曾在2017年邀请迈克尔上节目讨论标志设计。在他半退休之际，我们再次邀请他回来谈谈他的职业生涯、设计理念以及平面设计中一些最有趣的趋势。这就是我与我的朋友迈克尔·贝鲁特的谈话。你今年早些时候宣布要从五角设计公司退下来。这对你来说意味着什么？
If you're involved in some creative art form, that could be architecture or acting or songwriting or or being a painter or a sculptor or being a graphic designer, you're aware of the fact that you have some sort of talent. And it's easy to sort of think that because it doesn't seem to be physical necessarily, you'll be able to do it forever. There are people who do creative things, performers who do things. things who realize that they can't do it forever. If you're a ballet dancer, you know that there's a limit to how long you can perform physically. If you're an athlete, you absolutely know there's a limit to how long you can perform. And I think one of the things that I noticed was I wasn't as good as doing as sort of like the doing of the design as I used to be.
如果你从事某种创意艺术形式，无论是建筑、表演、作曲、绘画、雕塑还是平面设计，你都会意识到自己拥有某种天赋。而且很容易认为，因为它不一定是体力劳动，所以你可以永远做下去。有些从事创意工作的人，有些表演者，他们意识到自己无法永远做下去。如果你是一名芭蕾舞演员，你知道身体表演是有极限的。如果你是一名运动员，你绝对知道表演是有极限的。我认为我注意到的事情之一是，我在设计执行方面不如以前那么得心应手了。
I could just tell it was like it was coming a little slower. people have these different sort of reservoirs of ability, I think they can draw on. And I think I sort of sense that mine, I could sort of see the shallows of mine. And it sort of made me think, you know, maybe I should figure out a way to design my way into some new thing. You don't know what that new thing is. And I realize it wouldn't be able to fully envision the new thing unless I had completely, or at least started moving away from the old thing. one of the ideas I had for this interview was sort of taking your, you know,
我能感觉到它变得有点慢了。我认为人们拥有不同的能力储备，可以从中汲取力量。我感觉到我的储备已经见底了。这让我觉得，也许我应该想办法设计出一条通往新事物的道路。你不知道那是什么新事物。我意识到，除非我完全或至少开始远离旧事物，否则我无法完全预见新事物。我为这次采访准备的想法之一是，以你的“名誉退休”身份，对你的职业生涯做一个小小的绩效评估。我想看看你是否愿意，你知道，配合我一下。好的，好的，请继续。那么，如果你能告诉我，你认为你最大的成就是什么？你职业生涯中最好的作品是什么？哦，好吧，这很有趣。人们确实会有最喜欢的项目。
emeritus status and like, and do a little bit of a performance review of your career. And I wanted to see if you would consider, you know, like if you could sort of go with me. Yeah, yeah, go ahead. And so if you could talk to me about like, you know, what do you think was your biggest achievement? What was your best work you've done in your career? Oh, well, there's like, I mean, it's funny. There are like favorite projects one has.
在我职业生涯中，有几个分水岭时刻。今天早些时候，在去曼哈顿录制这期节目的路上，我骑着城市自行车沿着第八大道行驶，正好经过《纽约时报》大楼的前面。当他们搬进现在所处的伦佐·皮亚诺（Renzo Piano）设计的总部时，我们负责了所有的标识设计，包括大楼前写着“The New York Times”的字样。我们面临的挑战是在大楼外侧、面向第八大道的地方放置一个标志。这是一栋横跨整个街区的大楼。这基本上是一个长达一个街区的标志。
There were a couple of watershed moments that I had as I was going along. Earlier today, on my way to record this session with you here in Manhattan, I rode a city bike up. Eighth Avenue went right by the front of the New York Times building. And we did all the signage for the New York Times building when they moved into the Renzo Piano headquarters that they occupy now, including the way it says the New York Times in front of the building. And we were faced with this challenge of putting a sign in the outside of the building, facing 8th Avenue. It's a block-wide building. This is a block-long sign, basically.
我们知道它必须写上“The New York Times”，就像在他们的网站或印刷报纸上一样。然而，建筑师伦佐·皮亚诺设计的大楼全是玻璃和钢结构。皮亚诺和他的团队设计了一种类似面纱的东西，由安装在大楼每一面的水平细陶瓷棒组成。所以如果你房间里有那种百叶窗，你知道的，它就像打开的百叶窗。当你透过《纽约时报》的窗户看时，你会感知到这些水平元素，但你可以直接看穿，看到外面任何你想看的东西，对吧？
We knew that it had to say the New York Times just as it does on their website or as it does on the printed newspaper. However, the architect Renzo Piano had designed a building. It was all glass and steel. Renzo Piano and his team designed these kind of like veils almost made out of horizontal. thin ceramic rods that are mounted on each face of the building. So it's sort of like open Venetian blinds, if you've ever had those in your room, you know. You perceive as you're looking through the windows of the times, you perceive these horizontal elements, but you can see right through and you can see whatever you want to look at outside, right?
我们被要求把我们的大标志贴在那些水平元素上。这个标志实际上有一层楼那么高。字母非常大，因为它们横跨了一个街区。我们提议，与其做一个大标志，不如把《纽约时报》的标志拆解成300多个更小的元素，它们组合在一起就能形成《纽约时报》的标志。但每一个元素都只是一个水平构件，被固定在那些水平杆上的特定位置。此外，为了增强我们认为会奏效的效果，我们让每一个构件都呈现出鸭嘴的形状。所以有一个水平向外突出的尖端，从里面是看不到的，因为它指向外面而不是里面。但如果它们安装得当，排列得完全准确，然后你站在街对面港务局大楼的人行道上，
And so it was upon those horizontal elements that we were expected to stick our big sign. And the sign is like literally one story tall. The letters are really big because they run a block long. And we propose that instead of one big sign that what would happen if we took the New York Times logo and broke it into 300 plus much smaller elements that in the aggregate would create the New York Times logo. But each one of them was just a horizontal element that would be stuck at a certain point onto those horizontal rods. And moreover, in order to enhance an effect we thought, we hope would work, we made each of them kind of have the shape of a duck bill. So there's a point that kind of protruded out horizontally that you wouldn't be able to see from inside because it was pointing out instead of in. But if they were all installed properly, all lined up exactly right, and then you were down on the sidewalk in front of the Port Authority building right across the street.
抬头看，你会看到一个看起来绝对清晰且不透明的《纽约时报》标志。所以这是一种很巧妙的小东西，如果你直视它们，如果你在楼上的某个办公桌吃午饭。我一直被告知，面对那个标志背面的是讣告部门，我觉得这很有趣，不知道为什么。但如果你坐在那里的办公桌前，你可以直接向外看，看到港务局大楼辉煌的外立面（讽刺）。但你有一个不错的视野，可以看到远处的新泽西州，你知道，我们根本不知道它是否会成功。然后有一天，我坐公交车沿着第八大道行驶，我想，他们不是应该这周安装那个标志吗？我一看，他们真的在安装。
and you looked up, you would see what appeared to be an absolutely legible and opaque New York Times logo sign there. So it's sort of this neat little thing where if you're looking at them straight on, if you're eating lunch at your desk up on one of the floors. And I was always told it was like the obituary department that was, that faced the back of that sign, which I thought was, there was something apropos about that. I don't know. But if you were at the desk there, you could look straight out and see the glorious facade of the Port Authority. building sarcasm. But you had a nice view of that and New Jersey beyond, you know, we had no idea would work. And then one day I was on a bus going up 8th Avenue and I thought, aren't they supposed to be installing that sign like this week? And I looked and they were actually installing it.
当时的情况是，我开始在公交车上大喊大叫并鼓掌，周围的乘客都在看我。我说：“成功了！成功了！”人们只是，好吧，这是纽约，所以人们只是礼貌地无视我。他们对我的崩溃表现出没有任何兴趣或关心，但我确实因为第八大道上的一个标志而崩溃了，就像人们常做的那样。那么作为对比，在我们的绩效评估中，你能想到一个你会做得不同的设计吗？哦天哪，有太多事情让我意识到那是错失的机会，或者像你回家爬楼梯时想到的那样，你知道，你本该说的话，你本该做的事。
And I was like one of those cases where I started like yelling and clapping on the bus with other passengers around me. And I was saying it works. It works. And people just literally, well, it's New York. So people just politely ignored me. They weren't, they, they exhibited no interest or concern about whatever breakdown I was having, but I was having a breakdown about a sign on 8th Avenue, as one does. So by contrast and sort of our performance review, can you think of a design that you would have done differently? Oh my God, there's so, like, there's so many things where I realized they were missed opportunities or that idea you have, the staircase as you're going home, you know, like the thing you should have said, the thing you should have said, the thing you should
你知道，这在我身上反复发生。有些东西我甚至无法直视，因为它代表了如此巨大的错失机会。现在，我要补充一点，其中许多项目，客户对成品非常非常满意。所以我几乎不想点名。好吧，我们能让你说出一个吗？
have done. You know, this happened over and over to me again. And some things I just can't look at because it just represents like such a missed opportunity. Now, I would add that many of these things, the client was really, really well satisfied with the thing. So I'm almost reluctant to name names and sort of ways. Well, can we get you to name one?
我试着想一个非常遥远的项目，这样说出来也没关系。或者他们非常满意，你知道，这只是你自己的想法。哦，好吧，早期的，非常早期的，这很有趣。那是我做过的最早的项目之一。我还在上学时做的。我花了大约15年才从中吸取正确的教训。当时我在辛辛那提大学上学。我常去市中心一个叫当代艺术中心的地方，
I'm trying to think that there's something so remote that it would be okay. Or like they were so satisfied and, you know, it's just your thing. Oh, well, I mean, the early, early, it was funny. It was like one of the first projects I ever did. I was still in school when I did it. And it took me probably 15 years to learn the right lesson from it. I was going to college at the University of Cincinnati. I hung out at a place downtown called the Contemporary Arts Center,
那是辛辛那提现代艺术的麦加。我得到了一份令人惊叹、出人意料的肥差，就是为他们举办的一场大型展览设计目录。展览的主题是戏剧艺术家罗伯特·威尔逊（Robert Wilson）的作品，他好像在过去一年内去世了。你知道，那是他为不同作品设计的草图、家具和布景的集合，其中最近的一部是《沙滩上的爱因斯坦》（Einstein on the Beach），
which was sort of mecca for modern art in Cincinnati. And I got this amazing, startling plum job, which was to design a catalog for a major exhibit they had. on the work of the theater artist Robert Wilson, who just died, I think, within the past year, actually. You know, it was a combination of his sketches and furniture and set pieces he had designed for different productions he had done, the most recent of which was Einstein on the beach,
这是他与菲利普·格拉斯（Philip Glass）合作完成的。所以他们需要一份目录，他们说会付给我1000美元来设计和制作这份目录。据我所知，我以前从未想过，甚至从未说出过“1000美元”这个词。所以我被惊呆了，我想，你知道，这就是那个时刻。然后我记得它的每一个方面都让我感到困惑。我以前从未听说过罗伯特·威尔逊。
which he had done in collaboration with Philip Glass. So they needed a catalog for this, and they said they would pay me $1,000 to design and produce this catalog. And I had never, like, thought, I'd never even like uttered the words a thousand dollars before to my knowledge. So I was like stunned by this and I thought, you know, this is, you know, this is the moment. And then I remember every aspect of it kind of baffled me. I didn't, I had never heard of Robert Wilson before.
我从未听说过菲利普·格拉斯，也没听说过《沙滩上的爱因斯坦》。那音乐听起来不像我听过的任何其他音乐，而且听这种音乐对我来说没什么用。我看到的只有大约5000字的文稿和40到50张带说明的图片。我知道我必须把这些东西做成一个8.5英寸宽、11英寸高、可能不超过64页的形式。将这些碎片拼凑在一起的技术要求完全占据了我。就我所做的一切而言。这很难做，但我完成得很好。三栏网格，通篇使用一种字号。
I'd never heard of Philip Glass nor Einstein on the beach. The music sounded like no other music I'd ever heard and like not, it was not like useful to me to be hearing this music. And all as I saw were, you know, about, you know, 5,000 words of manuscript and 40 to 50 images with captions. And I knew I had to bring this thing into a form that would be a and a half inches wide, 11 inches tall, and probably no more than 64 pages long. And the technical requirements of jigsawing those hunks of thing together completely occupied me. in terms of all I did. And it was hard to do, and I acquitted myself well. A three-column grid, one type size throughout.
网格部署得很好。排版也非常漂亮。大约15年后，在布鲁克林音乐学院，我看了《沙滩上的爱因斯坦》的演出。你知道，这是你能体验到的最震撼、最迷人、最催眠、最沉浸、最极致、最理智、最感性且最美学的体验。它就像，你知道，我的意思是，它太强大了。我记得当时想，
The grid was deployed nicely. The typography is all very nice. About 15 years later, at the Brooklyn Academy Music, I saw a production of Einstein at the beach. And, you know, it's like the most physically powerful, enthralling, hypnotic, immersive, over-the-top, intellectual, and emotional and aesthetic experience. you can have. It's like, you know, I mean, it's just, it's so powerful. And I remember thinking,
我没有把这其中的哪怕一毫米融入到我1980年为1000美元做的那个愚蠢的目录里。即使是现在，每次，我不知道有多少，你可以，这些很难，这是昂贵且稀有的东西。如果你试图在eBay或其他地方买到这些东西，买到这些很久以前的晦涩小册子是很贵的。每次我看到它，我就想自杀。这简直是……它们很贵是因为你在买下所有副本去烧掉吗？不，也许我应该，是的。
I didn't get one millimeter of this into that stupid catalog I did for a thousand bucks back in 1980. And even now, every time, like, I don't know how many, you can, these are hard, this is an expensive, rare thing to buy. If you try to get one of these things on eBay or something, it's expensive to get one of these catalogs from this obscure little thing way back in the day. And every time I see it, I just, like, want to kill myself. It's just like... Are they expensive because you're buying all the copies to burn? No, maybe I should, yeah.
我的意思是，这有点……它太……它太无能了，而且从那以后我犯的每一个大错误都是那次经历的某种体现。有些事情我没有足够早地意识到，有些事情我不知道。如果我早知道这些，我会以不同的方式思考它。很多时候，在我职业生涯的前半段，
I mean, it's sort of a... It's just so... It was so inept and, like, and almost every big error I've made ever since then was some aspect of that. There was something that I didn't realize soon enough, something I didn't know. And had I only known that, I would have thought differently about it. And a lot of times, for the first half my career,
客户试图告诉我一些事情，而我太忙于和他们争论，所以他们最终按我的方式做了。然后我终于在某个时候，你知道，在90年代学会了闭嘴倾听，当有疑问时，只是问另一个问题，让他们说。我知道那种尴尬，那种作品，你意识到，哦，你遇到了一个新事实，一个新事物，然后想，为什么我15年前在对这些一无所知的时候会表达某种观点？但你必须这样做。那是你的工作，去表达那个观点，你用你所拥有的东西去工作。而且，你知道，我的意思是，变老的一件事是，如果你尊重好奇心随着年龄增长带给你的机会，你会变得越来越聪明，越来越睿智。而且，他们无法夺走这一点。你知道，你在实际工艺方面的技巧可能开始退化一点。但你拥有这种经验储备，如果你不沉迷于
the clients were trying to tell me, and I was too busy arguing with them, so they would do it my way. And then I finally, somewhere along the way, you know, learned, somewhere in the 90s learned to shut up and listen to when in doubt, just asking other question and let them talk. I know that embarrassment, like, that of work, and you realize, like, oh, you come across a new fact, a new thing and just like, why in the world did I express some opinion about this 15 years ago when I had no idea of stuff? But you had to. You had to. There was your job to express that opinion, and you worked with what you had. And, you know, I mean, that's the one thing by getting older, if you're, if you're, if you're, if you respect, you know, the opportunities that curiosity afford you as you age, you get smarter and smarter and quote unquote wiser and wiser, say. And that, they can't take that away from you. You know, you might not be your chops in terms of actually doing the craft may start to recede a little bit. But you sort of have this reservoir of experiences that if you don't get too enamored with. with tales from the good old days and bore people with those.
过去的好时光并用那些故事去烦扰别人。但如果你积极地保持好奇心，谁也说不准你能发现什么样的东西。谈到亮点，我想谈谈你更雄心勃勃的设计项目之一，《公告牌》（Billboard）排行榜，你对其进行了彻底的重新设计。顺便说一句，在读你的书之前，我根本不知道《公告牌》排行榜的起源。是的，它已经存在很长时间了，它在很久以前基本上是嘉年华的行业杂志。所以它多年来一直与美国娱乐界联系在一起，但直到世纪中叶以后才真正与音乐建立了联系。
But if you're actively kind of curious, there's no telling, you know, what kind of stuff you can discover. Talking about highlights, I want to talk about one of your more ambitious design projects, the Billboard Charts, which you totally redesigned. By the way, I had no idea about the origins of the Billboard charts until I read your book. Yeah, it's been around for a long time, and it was like a trade magazine for carnivals, basically, way back when. So it's sort of associated with the American world of entertainment for years, but only really acquired the association with music, you know, mid-century and beyond that.
是的，它就像《公告牌》的行业杂志。是的，为那些宣传马戏团等活动的人准备的。这太有趣了。当你想到它就在你面前时，这很有道理。《公告牌》百强榜，他们对最受欢迎的歌曲进行排名。最初的排行榜只是一个列表。就是这样。你重新设计了它。你添加了颜色和不同的字体大小，让新版本真正脱颖而出。
Yeah, it was like a trade magazine for Billboard. Yeah, for people advertising circuses and things. It's so funny. It just makes sense when you think about it's right there in front of you. But the Billboard top 100 charts, they rank the most popular songs. And the original chart was just a list. And that's it. redesigned it. You added color and different font sizes and things that really pop out in this new version.
它感觉更有活力。感觉更感性。你能谈谈那个重新设计吗？关心它的人真的很关心。我对此感到非常高兴。我知道，当你的歌登上榜首时，你会把它装裱起来挂在墙上，你知道吗？所以我必须做一些配得上那一刻的事情。所以基本上《公告牌》百强榜或《公告牌》上的排行榜都在做同样的事情。它们所做的是，至少只是把它们从1到40或1到100或1到200，或者无论你在特定排行榜上有多少首歌，按美国或世界范围内，或按流派等，最畅销的歌曲或专辑进行排列，对吧？所以它们必须被列出来。我相信还有歌曲的标题。它可能是唱片公司、词曲作者或表演者，显然还有歌曲的作者。
It feels more vibrant. It feels more like emotional. Could you talk about that redesign? People who cared about it, cared about it. And I was really happy about that. I knew that, you know, when your song hits number one, you're going to frame this and hang it on your wall, you know? And so I have to do something that is up to that moment, you know. So basically the Billboard top 100 or the charts in Billboard are all doing the same thing. And what they're doing is. is at minimum just kind of lining up from like 1 to 40 or 1 to 100 or 1 to 200 or however many you're on the particular chart, like the top selling, quote unquote, songs or albums in America or in the world or in genres or whatever it is, right? And so they have to be listed. There's also, I believe, it's the title of the song. It could be the label that it's on the writer or the performer, obviously, the writers of the song.
你可以从中获得大量信息。但我认为这在某种程度上也是一种对排行榜进行热力图分析的方式，他们多年来以不同的方式做过，试图说明哪些歌曲的排名跃升幅度最大。当我们重新设计它时，我们开始通过我们为单个条目设置的颜色来构建可视化这些信息的方法。所以你可以一眼看出。你可以阅读不同层级的信息，不仅仅是从1到多少的排名，甚至只是看着这个排行榜就能获得一点音乐背后的氛围。我认为这就是伟大的信息设计。我不是物理学家，但人们可以看元素周期表，它在某种程度上与他们对话，不仅仅是因为他们知道那些令人困惑的缩写代表什么。
There's lots of information you could get onto it. But I think it was sort of like a way of heat mapping the charts as well that they've done in different ways over the years where they were trying to say what songs have made the biggest leap up. And when we redesigned it, we sort of started building in ways to kind of visualize that by what color we were making the individual entries. So you could kind of see at a glance. You could kind of read different levels of information, not just the kind of rundown from one to what. whatever, but also kind of get a little behind the music vibes, even just from looking at this chart. And I think that's what great information design is. I'm not a physicist, but people can look at the periodic table of the elements and kind of, it speaks to them at a certain level because, not just because they know what each of those confounding abbreviations stand for.
为什么PB不能代表铅呢？但他们也可以通过方块上的位置、相邻的元素、相关的原子序数来判断。所有这些都在讲述这些非常复杂、丰富的故事。我认为当你做像这些排行榜这样的事情时，你是在尝试，只是添加尽可能多的信息，试图弄清楚你能把多少信息塞进去。你知道，数据可视化，这就是信息设计。设计这样的图表你所做的就是这些。
Why wouldn't PB stand for lead, for instance? But they also can tell by the position on the square, what are adjacent to them, what are the numbers, atomic numbers, associated. All those things are telling these really complicated, rich stories. And I think when you're doing something like those charts, you're trying to, like, just add as much, trying to figure out how much information can you cram into them. You know, data visualization, it's information design. It's all you're doing with designing a chart like that.
但它也做了一些事情，每一首歌，正如奥斯卡·王尔德曾经说过的“廉价音乐的力量”，你知道，它确实与人们产生了联系，它是令人难忘的，它意味着什么。而你是做这项工作时的守护者。休息之后，迈克尔·贝鲁特是一位平面设计师，但他也是一位多产的设计评论家。我将问迈克尔关于最近的几个设计趋势，包括佐兰·马姆达尼（Zoran Mamdani）纽约市长竞选中的病毒式设计。更多关于迈克尔·贝鲁特的内容，稍后回来。我们回到了设计师迈克尔·贝鲁特身边。每隔一段时间，我看到一个东西，我
But it's also doing something where each one of those songs, power of cheap music, as Oscar Wilde once said, you know, it sort of really does, you know, connect up with people, and it's memorable and it means something. And you're the custodian of that. doing that work. After the break, Michael Beirut is a graphic designer, but he's also a prolific design critic. I'm going to ask Michael about a couple of recent design trends, including the viral designs from the New York City mayoral campaign of Zoran Mamdani. More with Michael Beirut. After this, we're back with designer Michael Beirut. Every once in a while, I see a thing and I
想，哦，我想问迈克尔关于这个的问题。我应该直接给你发邮件。但当我看到一个设计趋势，或者看到引起很多关注的设计时。我只是想听听你的看法。我想从你熟悉的领域开始，纽约政治。佐兰·马姆达尼的竞选活动因其设计而受到很多赞扬。它使用了大胆的颜色和与你习惯的政治竞选不同的字体。它已经变得有点“模因化”了，我不知道这是否是成功的标志，或者只是某种东西的标志。我只是想听听你的看法。你觉得它怎么样，你认为它在做什么？佐兰·马姆达尼在他的竞选活动中和他一起工作的设计师所做的是，几乎每一个元素，图形元素，都有人们熟悉的先例。
think, oh, I want to ask Michael about this. And I should just email you about it. But when I see a design trend, or I see designs that have gotten a lot of tension. I just want to get your vibe on it. And I wanted to start in your neck of the woods with New York politics. The Zoran Mundani campaign received a lot of praise for its design. It used bold colors and different fonts than what you're used to in a political campaign. It's become kind of memeified, which I don't know if that's like an indication of success or something or just an indication of something. I just wanted to get your take on it. What do you think about it and what do you think it's doing? What Zohr and Mom Dami did with his campaign and his designers who worked with him on it is that almost every single element, graphic element, sort of had a precedent that people were familiar with.
它有一种深黄、橙、蓝的组合，人们从出租车到带他们出地铁的地铁卡都能认出来。橙色和蓝色也是尼克斯队（Knicks）和大都会队（Mets）等纽约队的颜色。所以这有点像是在玩那个梗。所有的字体都让人联想到你在杂货店和街角小店看到的那些手绘字体。所以非常有街头文化感，我不认为这是一种迎合，而是一种似乎真正植根于候选人的背景和兴趣的方式。你知道，然后我认为，嗯，任何了解政治的人听这个，我不想让他们认为，一个设计播客上的平面设计师在想，这就是他获胜的原因。任何人。
It had a deep yellow, orange, blue combination that people would recognize from everything from taxi cabs to their metro cards that got them out of the subway. orange and blues also kind of the New York colors of the Knicks and the Mets, et cetera, et cetera. So it was a little bit of a play on that. The lettering all kind of evoked, the hand-painted lettering you see in grocery stores and bodegas. So very much street corner street culture, not in a way that was pandering, I didn't think, but in a way that actually seemed truly rooted in what the candidates' background and interests were. You know, and then I think the, um, anyone who knows politics listening to this, I wouldn't want them to think that, you know, a graphic designer on a design podcast is thinking, and that's why he won. Anyone.
那些颜色和那些字体以及那些参考点，你知道。嗯，不，但我的意思是，显然他将这一点与一种绝对独特的能力结合起来，即以我所说的非常具体的垂直视频、适合TikTok的交流模式与人们建立联系，这对年轻人来说非常非常熟悉。我本来想说年轻人，但祖母和祖父们也在看。我认为你意识到很少有人能对此感到自在。你知道，你必须觉得你需要一种舞者的优雅来完成那种“边走边谈”的视频，并将他们与他的直接竞争对手进行比较，并将他们与你看到的试图做这件事的大多数人进行比较，你知道。他只是有这种奇迹般的，你知道，我的意思是，我不能，在某种程度上，这就像约翰·肯尼迪（John Kennedy）在与尼克松（Nixon）的第一次电视辩论中，人们突然意识到这是两位完全正常的政治候选人，但其中一个人在电视上看起来确实很好，那种神奇的品质是什么？而且，你知道，世界上所有的化妆和准备工作都没能让尼克松达到那个水平。
Those colors and those tight faces and those points of reference, you know. Um, no, but I mean, obviously he combined that with an absolute unique ability to connect with people in what I would say very specifically is the vertical video, TikTok ready. mode of address that is very, very familiar to young. I was going to say young people, but grandmothers and grandfathers watch it as well. And I think you sort of realize how few people are at ease in that. You know, you sort of have to feel you need a kind of dancer's grace with your body to pull that off to do a walk and talk like that and compare them to his immediate competitors and compare them to most people you see trying to do that, you know. And he just had this miraculous, you know, I mean, I can't, it's in a way, it's sort of like John Kennedy in the first debates with Nixon that were televised, where all of a sudden people realized these are two perfectly regular political candidates, but one of them seems to really look good on TV and what is that magical quality. And, you know, all the makeup and prep in the world never got Nixon there.
而肯尼迪拥有它。然后我认为图形设计语言在他所在的地方与他相遇。是的。你知道，我一直这么想。我有很多伟大的想法和很多伟大的设计作品，但你真的需要一个伟大的客户才能做出好的作品。你不能只是走出去说，这是伟大的设计作品，谁在买，或者谁想欣赏。
And JFK had it. And then I think the graphic design language met him where he was. Yeah. You know, and I think this all the time. I've had lots of great ideas and lots of great design work, but you really need a great client in order to do good work. You can't just kind of like go out there and say, here's great design work, who's buying or who wants to admire.
你必须与客户建立联系。你知道，在这种情况下，我认为这是一系列精心挑选、精心校准和管理的图形标准的结合，这些标准实际上直接从人们非常熟悉的事物中汲取灵感。我认为这很有趣，因为这是一种真理，你可能以前听我说过。我上次采访你时可能说过，但当我读到雷蒙德·洛威（Raymond Loewy）的那个理论时，即所有设计都是在熟悉和新颖之间协商的，人们对这两者都有双重需求。
You sort of like need to connect up with a client. You know, in this case, I think it was a combination of, really well-chosen, really carefully calibrated and administered graphic standards that actually drew their inspiration directly from things that people were really familiar with. And I think it's interesting because that's sort of, it's a truism, and you may have heard me say this before. I may have said this the last time you interviewed me, but when I read that theory that Raymond Lowy has is that all design is sort of negotiated. between the familiar and the novel, and people have this dual appetites for those two things.
你知道，他们想体验新事物，但如果他们整天体验的都是新事物，这会变得令人筋疲力尽和迷失方向，你会把头埋在枕头下。但如果你体验的都是熟悉的事物，这里有一种舒适感，但它会变得无聊，对吧？所以我想，你知道，
You know, they want to experience new things, but if all as they experience all day long are new things, it becomes exhausting and disorienting, and you put your head under the pillow. But if all you experience is familiar things, there's an element of comfort there, but it gets boring, right? And so I think, you know,
每次设计师，特别是工作是与人交流的平面设计师，在选择我们将要进行工作的成分时。你是在试图选择那些能唤起人们熟悉元素的东西，然后以一种仍然看起来令人惊讶、引人注目和与众不同的方式来做。你知道，我们明年有中期选举，我觉得我们将看到数百万场竞选活动使用佐兰的那种品牌推广，带有看起来与传统竞选活动不同的新字体和颜色，但是，你知道，可能看起来彼此非常相似。
every time a designer, particularly a graphic designer whose job it is to communicate, with people is picking the ingredients by which we're going to do the work. You're sort of trying to pick things that will evoke familiar elements to people and then somehow do it in a way that still seems surprising and arresting and differentiating. You know, we have midterms next year, and I feel like we're going to see millions of campaigns that use Zoron's, you know, type of branding with like new fonts and colors that look different from traditional campaigns, but, you know, maybe look a lot like each other.
这就像，你知道，设计中的一切都是这样的。当某件事成功时，你就会到处看到它。这让我想到了我想和你谈论的另一件事，那就是书封。你设计了很多书封。现在感觉每隔一本封面就像是一幅画，正面有大而醒目的字体。我认为书封非常有趣，因为它们结合了两种看起来几乎相反的东西。一是，你知道，它们在回应内容，你知道，有时你在创作设计，几乎没有什么内容可以利用，对吧？嗯。
which is like, you know, this is everything in design is like this. Like when something is successful, then you see it everywhere. And which brings me to one of the other things I want to talk to you about, which is book covers. Like you've designed a lot of book covers. And right now it feels like every other book cover is like a painting with like a big bold type on the front of it. I think book covers are really interesting because they're combining two things that seem almost opposite. One is, you know, they're responding to content that, you know, sometimes you're creating design and there's hardly any content to work with, right? Mm-hmm.
你知道，你正在为某家人工智能公司做初创项目，他们阅读了简报，它可能与另外2200家公司完全相同，你知道。他们有一个荒谬的名字，你只需要想办法让它以某种方式再活一天，对吧？然而，对于一本书，有人确实倾注了他们的心血。一个人类倾注了他们的心血，至少到目前为止，在很大程度上，倾注了他们的心血在一本他们关心的书上，而这本书正在寻找读者，对吧？但为了获得这些读者，它必须在消费品包装的层面上竞争，就像一盒麦片、一袋薯片或一瓶能量饮料一样。然后它就回归到你在做消费品包装时必须做的所有事情。
You know, you're doing startup for some AI company and they read the brief and it sort of could be identical to 2,200 others, you know. They've got some preposterous name and you just have to figure out a way to make it, you know, live another day somehow, right? With the book, though, someone's actually poured their heart and soul. A single human beings pour their heart and soul, at least so far, for the most part, pour their heart and soul into a book that they care about, and the book is seeking readers, right? But then to get those readers, it has to compete at the level of consumer product packaging, just like a box of cereal or a bag of potato chips or a bottle of energy drink. and it then kind of reverts to all the things you have to do when you're doing consumer packaging.
所以我认为书封趋势中发生的很多事情，只是试图向人们发出信号：如果你喜欢这种东西，这就是你会喜欢的东西。就像达尔文在他的著作中所说的那样，会发生突变，如果它们成功了，最终会通过所谓的选择，创造出一条通往新事物的进化路径。什么？自然选择，是的。所以我想，你知道，每个人都会想，哦，我想要，好吧，你知道，人们会看到那个并想，你知道，我想捕捉那种氛围。我的意思是，我记得《引爆点》（The Tipping Point）刚出来的时候。哦，是的。是的。我有太多的出版商来找我，他们，而且这本书总是同一种书。这是一本非虚构类书籍。关于一个听起来像大学课程水平社会学之类的学科，
So I think a lot of things that happen with trends and book covers are, it's just trying to signal to people, if you like this sort of thing, this is the sort of thing you'll like. And just like Darwin said in his writing, there are mutations that will happen that if they're successful end up kind of creating a new evolutionary path to something new through, what's I called, selective? What? Natural selection, yeah. And so I think, you know, everyone sort of thinks, oh, I want, well, you know, people will sort of see that and think, you know, I want to catch that sort of vibe. I mean, I remember when the tipping point first came out. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I had so many publishers that would come to me and they sort of, and the book was always the same kind of book. It was a nonfiction book. on a subject that sounded like college course level sociology or something,
但写它的人想出了一种巧妙的方法，让它看起来平易近人、生动活泼，值得参加播客节目之类的。他们会说，好吧，你知道，你做你想做的任何事。但是，你知道，我想有很多留白，如果有图片，也许它就像一张小图片，你知道，然后字体应该感觉有点文学气息。就像，我会说你正在描述马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell）的《引爆点》的封面，我想它有，你知道，它用小写全大写衬线字体写着“The Tipping Point”，用全大写衬线字体写着“by Malcolm Gladwell”。在中间，我忘了是否有一根火柴棍或某种淹没在留白中的小东西。而且，像，你知道，而且你可以看出，有趣的是，它们不是，这令人沮丧和恼火。
but whoever had written it had come up with this kind of clever way of making it seem accessible and lively and worthy of podcast appearances or something. And they would say, okay, you know, you do whatever you want. But, you know, I think a lot of white space, if there's an image, maybe it's like a little image, you know, and then the type should feel kind of literary. And like, I'd say you're describing the cover of the tipping point by Malcolm Gladwell, which I think had, you know, it said the tipping point in little all caps serf typography, said by Malcolm Gladwell in all caps serf typography. In between, I forget if there was like a match stick or some little same size thing drowning in white space. And I, and like, you know, and you can tell, like, what's funny is that they weren't, it was frustrating and aggravating.
我假设对于所有书封设计师甚至许多作者来说都是如此，但他们试图做的是只是为“如果你喜欢这个，你就会喜欢那个”穿上戏服。他们只是试图在视觉上支持算法推荐，即“购买了《引爆点》的人也喜欢这个”，你知道吗？我们如何通过设计来发出这个信号？所以我认为很多趋势，时期，都是因为这个而发生的。你知道，我认为每一个设计都在同时试图看起来像你以前从未见过的东西，但它必须在足够熟悉的东西内运作，这样你才能在自己的知识领域内处理它。
And I assume for all book cover designers and even for many authors, But what they were trying to do was kind of just get in costume for, you know, if you like this, you'll like that. They're just trying to like kind of visually support the algorithmic recommendation of people who bought the tipping point also enjoy this, you know? And how do we signal that with design? So I think a lot of trends, period, happened because of that. You know, I think every design is simultaneously trying to look like something you've never seen before, but it has to operate within something sufficiently familiar that you can prove. process it within your own field of knowledge in a way.
你说过你最喜欢的书封之一是旧平装本，栗色的《麦田里的守望者》（Catcher in the Rye）平装本。它只是文字，带有某种栗色背景。为什么你那么喜欢那一个？好吧，当我这么说时，我是对书封粉丝说的。我指的是具体，我忘了是谁，我想是Bantam Books，出版了那个平装本。《麦田里的守望者》过去有这种栗色
You've said that one of your favorite book covers is the old paperback, the maroon paperback of Catcher in the Rye. It is just text with a sort of maroon background. Why do you like that one so much? Well, when I say that, I'm book cover fans out there. I'm referring specifically to, I forget who had the, I think it was Bantam books, published the paperback. Kester and the Rye used to have this murray.
封面，上面没有任何图片，只有黄色的全大写Times Roman字体写的“Catcher in the Rye”。在它下面较小的全大写Times Roman黄色字体是作者的名字J.D.塞林格（J.D. Salinger）。就像我记得在读那本书之前，感觉到它是被禁止的，在某种程度上有点危险。我习惯于阅读，你知道，他们当时不叫它年轻成人小说，但我读了很多《哈迪兄弟》（Hardy Boys）之类的书。我记得看到那本书并想，其他每一本书上都有图片，一张像我一样的孩子做孩子事情的图片，而且它应该是很有趣的。
Roon cover with no image on it at all and just the words Catcher in the Rye in all caps, Times Roman in yellow. And underneath it smaller in all caps, Times Roman's yellow was the author's name J.D. Salinger. Like I remember before I had read that book, perceiving that it was forbidden and slightly dangerous in a way. And I was used to reading, you know, they didn't call it young adult fiction there. but I was like, I read a lot of Hardy Boys and stuff like that. I remember seeing that book and thinking every other book had a picture on it, a picture of kids like me doing kids' stuff, and it was supposed to be fun.
Roon的封面上面没有任何图片，只有全大写的“麦田里的守望者”几个字，用的是黄色的Times Roman字体。在它下面，用较小的黄色Times Roman字体写着作者的名字J.D.塞林格。我记得在读那本书之前，我就觉得它有一种被禁的、稍微有点危险的感觉。我当时习惯读的，你知道，那时候还不叫青少年小说，但我读了很多《哈迪男孩》之类的书。我记得看到那本书时心想，别的书封面上都有图，画着像我一样的孩子在做孩子做的事，那应该很有趣才对。
And then here's this book that only has type on it. And I only knew one other book that looked like that, and that was the Bible. The Bible said, Holy Bible, King James Edition. And that's all I had in the cover. So I thought, well, this book must have some weight to it. I remember from the first sentence, just being absolutely mesmerized by it. It was a tone of voice. I didn't know it was legal to print in books.
然后这里有一本书，上面只有文字。我只知道另一本看起来像这样的书，那就是《圣经》。《圣经》上写着“圣经，英王钦定本”。封面就只有这些。所以我心想，这本书一定很有分量。我记得读第一句话时，我就完全被它迷住了。那是一种语调。我当时不知道在书里印这种内容是合法的。
And it just spoke to me like someone was talking to me face to face. And I associated the connection, the emotional connection I had with the book, to the mysterious presentation of the cover. And there's just some, you know, all of us have things like that. It could be an album cover. It could be a band logo. It could be a fashion brand for some people. And there's just something about, you know, the way that they've chosen to present it.
它就像有人在面对面跟我说话一样。我把这种联系，即我与这本书的情感联系，与它神秘的封面呈现方式联系在了一起。你知道，我们每个人都有这样的东西。它可能是一张专辑封面，一个乐队标志，或者对某些人来说是一个时尚品牌。它们呈现的方式确实有些特别之处。
and the way it connected with you at a certain moment in your life, emotionally, that you sort of invested with all this meaning, that in a way you can't point to anything about it that sort of is the carrier of that meaning. It's two colors. It's the most banal typeface in the world times Roman, you know, and it's the most default typeface in the world. So there's something about it that was just so evocative to me
以及它在你生命中某个时刻与你产生的情感共鸣，让你赋予了它所有的意义，以至于你无法指出它身上有什么东西是这种意义的载体。它只有两种颜色。它是世界上最平庸的字体——Times Roman，你知道的，它是世界上最默认的字体。所以它身上确实有些东西让我感到非常触动
that sort of made me realize that emotionally design can work in a lot of ways, but what it always needs, I think, is a reference. It has to be representing something that actually carries that weight. It can't invent that weight out of nothing. We are running out of time, unfortunately. You've talked about your retirement in other places, and you said that you're going to miss, you know, the design challenge, but mostly you're going to miss working with your team. And I'm wondering if you could talk a bit more about that.
这让我意识到，设计在情感上可以以多种方式发挥作用，但我认为它始终需要一个参照物。它必须代表某种真正具有分量的东西。它不能凭空创造出这种分量。很遗憾，我们的时间不多了。你在其他地方谈到过你的退休，你说你会怀念设计挑战，但最怀念的还是与团队共事。我想请你多谈谈这一点。
Design is the most wonderful thing in the world. The things that we would say in meetings, and a lot of times, I would come home and Dorothy would say, you know, how his work? And increasingly, my report would be someone who worked for me just designed the greatest thing. And like, I can't tell you how many times I would sort of like bring the whole office to a halt screaming. Sometimes, like, swearing, like, you know, God damn it, you motherfucker. And I just would be like laughing my hands. It just was just so fun to see someone, you know, hit on something like that. And it didn't happen every day, but boy, you know, those days when it did happen, it would make my day.
设计是世界上最美妙的事情。我们在会议上说的话，很多时候，我回到家，多萝西会问我工作怎么样。而我的回答越来越多的是，我手下的某个人刚刚设计出了最棒的东西。我无法告诉你，有多少次我会让整个办公室停下来，大声尖叫。有时甚至会骂人，比如“该死，你这混蛋”。我只是笑得合不拢嘴。看到有人能做出那样的作品，真的太有趣了。虽然不是每天都会发生，但天哪，那些发生的日子，真的让我的一天都变得美好。
And what's so funny is it didn't matter to me at all, whether it was happening to me or happening to someone else. Even having this, I was in the office a few weeks ago. And two of my partners were working on something, a project that I was aware of. And they said, you want to see how that came out? And they showed me the thing they were going to propose to the client. And it was so perfect. I kind of just was like, God, damn, I can't believe you did that.
有趣的是，无论是发生在我身上还是别人身上，对我来说都一样。即使是现在，几周前我在办公室时，我的两个合伙人正在做一个我知情的项目。他们问我：“想看看结果如何吗？”他们给我看了他们打算向客户提议的作品。它太完美了，我当时就想：“天哪，真不敢相信你们做到了。”
It's so great. It just would make me so happy. So, I mean, I love design, but that doesn't mean I need to do all of the design in the world. I mean, I love it as a spectator as much as a participant. Yeah. I feel the same way as my sort of show has grown on all the people, like, are, you know, really just more talented than me. You know, and it's sort of just, that just feels like pride. I feel so good about it.
太棒了。这真的让我非常开心。所以，我的意思是，我热爱设计，但这并不意味着我需要完成世界上所有的设计。我的意思是，作为观众和作为参与者一样，我都热爱它。是的，我的感觉也一样，随着我的节目成长，所有的人都比我更有才华。你知道，这感觉就像是一种骄傲。我对此感觉非常好。
Like, I always do. I always say that people's career Like in the beginning You don't know how to do the thing you do But you try And then in the middle of your career You're like there's one way to do it And it's my way. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
就像我常说的，人们的职业生涯，刚开始时你不知道该怎么做，但你会尝试。到了职业生涯中期，你会觉得“只有一种方法可以做到，那就是我的方法”。是的，没错。
And then the end of your career, you're like There's a million ways to do it And probably anyone could do it And probably as long as you execute it well Like I can be convinced You know like You just kind of get sanguine at this stage Of just enjoying people solving a problem
到了职业生涯末期，你会觉得“有无数种方法可以做到，而且可能任何人都能做到，只要你执行得好”。我可以被说服。你知道，在这个阶段，你只是变得乐观，享受看着别人解决问题
in a way that you wouldn't solve. And I love that feeling. I cannot tell you how much I love that feeling. I'm a musical theater aficionado. And one of my heroes, it's the late Stephen Sondheim, who is famous first as a lyricist for West Side Story, but then he began writing full musicals and sort of became a music and lyrics guy. You know, a million shows that were just amazing.
用一种你不会采用的方式。我喜欢那种感觉。我无法告诉你我有多喜欢那种感觉。我是音乐剧爱好者。我的偶像之一是已故的斯蒂芬·桑德海姆，他首先作为《西区故事》的作词人而闻名，后来他开始创作完整的音乐剧，成为了一名词曲作家。你知道，他创作了无数令人惊叹的剧目。
And he had a run in the middle that was just like one odd, thing after another. And then, you know, he lived into his 90s, but I would say along the way, probably even as early as his 60s, he started, you know, somehow he didn't quite have it anymore, if asked me. And this is someone who admires him beyond all words. And, you know, in his last decades, he really just had a few shows, some of which never really got completely worked out.
他在中期有一段时期，作品一部接一部地精彩。后来，他活到了90多岁，但我会说，在他职业生涯的某个阶段，可能早在60多岁时，他似乎就有点力不从心了，如果问我的话。而我是一个对他无比崇拜的人。你知道，在他最后的几十年里，他确实只有几部作品，其中一些甚至从未完全打磨好。
None of them were world-shaping hits the way that, or influences in the culture even, that his earlier work worlds. On the other hand, every other day I'll encounter online a letter that he wrote to a young person in the theater. And it isn't like the polite right back to fans. It was like you can tell that they didn't know he was in the audience to see this workshop show. And he had to write a letter afterwards just complimenting them. You don't know me, but we've never had a chance of me, but I just have to tell you how I'm thralling I was when I saw that production of blah, blah, blah.
没有一部作品像他早期的作品那样具有世界性的影响力，甚至在文化上也没有产生同样的影响。另一方面，我几乎每隔一天就会在网上看到他写给年轻戏剧人的信。那不是那种礼貌地回复粉丝的信。你可以看出，他们甚至不知道他当时就在观众席看这场工作坊演出。他必须在事后写信给他们，称赞他们。你可能不认识我，我们从未有机会见面，但我必须告诉你，当我看到那场演出时，我是多么着迷。
And I just, I mean, I just read one. Someone just published one he wrote the other day. And when he died, you know, people surfaced, and they said, I was no one. And I got this letter from Steven Sondheim. And it, like, you know, it gave me the courage to go on. So I think, you know, if you're looking for a worthy thing to do in your golden years, Roman, or.
我刚刚读了一封。有人前几天刚发表了一封他写的信。当他去世时，人们纷纷站出来说：“我当时什么都不是，但我收到了斯蒂芬·桑德海姆的这封信。”这给了我继续前进的勇气。所以我想，如果你正在寻找在晚年值得做的事情，罗曼，或者。
Michael. You know, you could do a lot worse than trying to figure out a way to make the world a better place, not by kind of going back to the grindstone with renewed flagging vigor, but to just identify the people that are really going to help move the world forward and give them everything, you know, give them all the support you can give them. I think it's really a beautiful thing to do. That is a perfect place to end this. Michael Beirut, thank you so much for talking with me. Roman, thank you. I wish we could do this. Well, we should do this like every. 10 years or so, maybe, see how that goes. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swanreale. Special thanks this week to CDM Studios in New York for recording Michael Beirut's side of the conversation.
迈克尔。你知道，你可以做很多比这更有意义的事，比如想办法让世界变得更美好，不是通过带着疲惫的精力重回工作岗位，而是去发掘那些真正能推动世界进步的人，并给予他们一切，给予他们你能提供的所有支持。我认为这是一件非常美好的事情。这是一个完美的结束点。迈克尔·贝鲁特，非常感谢你与我交谈。罗曼，谢谢你。我希望我们能经常这样做。嗯，我们应该每10年左右做一次，看看情况如何。《99% Invisible》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由Swanreale创作。本周特别感谢纽约的CDM Studios录制了迈克尔·贝鲁特的对话部分。
Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
凯西·2是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括杰森·德里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉沙马顿、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are a part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI, and I recommend you listen to the other Michael Pate 1. really, really great. You can hear it at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Series XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有链接，还有《99PI》过去的所有剧集，我建议你听听另一期迈克尔·贝鲁特的节目，真的很棒。你可以在99PI.org收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。